[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans ce set 8
sport sur tv 60,18 l'émission ne pas
manquer si vous êtes un passionné de
sport local c'est parti pour le sommaire
de ce magazine cyclisme coup de
projecteur sur la 80e édition de
paris-nice la course au soleil de départ
était une nouvelle fois reprogrammé dans
les yvelines sommes allés du côté de
mantes la ville et d'auffargis les
villes départ de cette saison 2022 long
reportage à suivre dans ce magazine
football épopée déversés en coupe de
france c'est terminé au stade des demi
finales les versets ils se sont inclinés
2 à 0 face à nice à l'extérieur nous
recevons des joueurs dans ce set 8 sport
enfin dehibi noise ont participé au raid
des alizés en novembre prochain
martinique un évènement 100% à féminin
nous avons rencontré zoé sophie
stéphanie assange amanlis l'actualité
sportive c'est maintenant sur tb 78
on va donc commencer par du cyclisme la
80e édition de paris-nice été lancée ce
dimanche depuis les yvelines comme
chaque année depuis 13 ans les cyclistes
ont pris le départ depuis deux communes
du département cette année ce sont
mantes-la-jolie ce dimanche et auffargis
ce lundi qui ont eu le privilège
d'accueillir les cyclistes nous étions
sur place des images de nicolas landry
un montage de xavier jaglin
[Musique]
aujourd'hui nous sommes samantha ville
pour assister à la 80e édition du
paris-nice la course au soleil partira
pour la 13ème année consécutive depuis
les yvelines et comme vous pouvez le
voir le soleil est bien au rendez vous
aujourd'hui dans les yvelines
[Musique]
la première étape est une boucle de
159,8 km à travers les yvelines et le
val d'oise avec départ et arrivée à
mantes-la-ville la commune située dans
le nord du département accueille pour la
première fois de son histoire le départ
de la course au soleil on est
complètement ravi donc effectivement
c'est un événement un événement sportif
et festif pour nous puisque ici on
organise donc derrière d'un derrière moi
donc le village d'animations alors c'est
certes la première course qui lance qui
lance la saison cycliste la course au
soleil au soleil au soleil à manta ville
on est vraiment très très heureux qu'est
ce que ça va apporter à une commune
comme mantes la ville alors évidemment
la ville va être mise en lumière
c'est la 80e édition de du paris-nice la
13e fois que sa part des yvelines et ça
va perdurer et donc le fait que ça parte
depuis de piment de la ville aujourd'hui
dans cette zone ce n'est pas anodin
c'est une zone qui est derrière moi là
qui fait 35 hectares qui va être
complètement développé avec à quelques
mètres l'arrivée le terminus du
rayonne dans toute cette zone va se
développer et on est vraiment de très
très content à le mettre en lumière donc
notre ville c'est son axe du
développement les habitants l'air ravi
vous êtes ravi également alors les
habitants n'ont pas l'air ravis ils sont
ravis on l'a vu on l'a vu déjà depuis
depuis quelques jours bien sûr on a
quelques contraintes en bloque la
circulation
on a le avait alors qu'ils arrivent donc
il ya des rues qui sont bloqués mais
néanmoins ils sont vraiment contents que
la ville soit 2 soit mise en lumière et
de profiter des animations et d'être
d'être au coeur d'un événement aussi
qu'on s'y retrouver
pour un revenu de norvège la 4e et 7e 4
au total plusieurs centaines de
personnes se sont rendues au tour du
village départ pour observer les
coureurs dans la foule on retrouve
évidemment des habitants de vente la
mise sans un bel événement vous regarde
le tour de france on les voit qu'on les
fasse dans les yvelines
c'est sympa de voir ça autour de chez
nous pour le coup je reste parce que
j'habite à mantes la ville et je suis
niçoise
donc voilà très content d'être là c'est
un super événement présente la vie
franchement ne re d'état certains ne se
contente pas de regarder ils sont venus
avec un objectif en tête essayez
d'obtenir un souvenir avec les cyclistes
pour immortaliser le moment
je fais signer le court
18 ans du passage des coureurs pour
mon fils est passionné de vélo donc on
en profite d'autres profitent de
l'événement pour faire du vélo entre
amis le jour j le paris-nice et en
annuel pour cette bande de cyclistes
nous on est venu de de paris donc on est
parti d'un vélo ce matin voir le
l'étape aujourd'hui par le départ de
l'étape et puis on va retourner ça fait
plaisir que maison fait on vient départ
c'est toujours un évènement ou pas ce
départ depuis les minimes ouais c'est ça
et puis ça c'est cool parce que c'est un
terrain de vélo assez sympa donc pour se
rendre à chaque fois on allait la faire
dédicacer quand
on a l'occasion de faire l'état routière
la veille on attend même et là on est
venu pour le départ on a faim on vient
de faire les 30 derniers kilomètres
laissant pas la fin d'étape 4 le rendez
vous a également attiré un public
international dans cette commune
yvelinoise de 19 mille habitants avec
notamment des supporters colombien
aujourd'hui nos sens là je sens mon pour
l'accompagner à nos seuls six colombiens
et
colombiennes dans l'équipe je pense que
c'est la
limite
on élimine soucie
pas de nice après la présentation des
cyclistes direction la ligne de départ
pour les organisateurs parmi eux pierre
bédier le président du département des
yvelines un nouveau départ depuis les
yvelines qu'est ce que ça vous fait 13e
départ c'est le partenariat avec aso
l'organisateur du paillis et du tour de
france et c'est le plein soleil il ya du
monde les gens sont heureux joyeux ça
nous sort un peu déçu si
internationaux avec le drame ukrainiens
et des soucis sanitaires donc c'était un
dimanche beaucoup de monde aujourd'hui
est ce que ça vous surprend non le vélo
est un sport extrêmement populaire et en
particulier dans les yvelines qui comme
chacun sait est le département où on
peut faire du vélo le mieux en ile de
france peut-être pas en france marne ile
de france à caution est ce que c'est une
belle promotion pour le vélo dans les
yvelines c'est une belle promotion pour
le vélo c'est une belle promotion pour
les villes c'est d'ailleurs l'objectif
pour mantes la ville pour son maire ses
amis d'énergie pour la population manque
la ville c'est un moment de faire
découvrir leur ville c'est un moment de
fierté c'est un moment de joie donc
c'est superbe
un partenariat qui devrait durer au
minimum jusqu'en 2025 le département
voudrait conserver cette course au
soleil au delà de cette date une envie
partagée par les organisateurs on aime
ou très satisfaites
l'autre partenariat avec le département
des yvelines depuis maintenant 2010 avec
le dimanche ce système de boucle on
repasse faire des villes à forte
population pour repartir plus dans des
territoires ruraux le lundi matin mais
oui bien sûr ça fait toujours plaisir de
voir du monde de voir des sourires de
voir des gens contents il ya une vraie
aspiration à revivre comme avant bien
évidemment qui nous touche tous au delà
du cyclisme et ça s'exprime là ce matin
sur paris nice et c'est agréable en
effet après un peu moins de 160 km de
course et christophe laporte mais front
ses deux jeunes fils maki s'imposant
cette première étape évinoise devant ses
coéquipiers rose litchi vanherpe la
première de sa carrière sur paris nice
je marche dans les banlieues d'eau
c'est vraiment du rapport mais voilà je
suis vraiment heureux
deuxième jour sur ce paris-nice 2022
aujourd'hui le départ est donné depuis
la petite commune d'auffargis 2000
habitants direction en les rangs pour
une étape de 159 kilomètres
[Musique]
à mes côtés daniel montrent le maire de
la commune d'auffargis alors daniel bond
est ce que c'est un plaisir de recevoir
pour la première fois le départ dit par
ellis c'est un plaisir c'est une fête
c'est un grand moment et tu regardais
voir
magnifique on a le soleil oui le soleil
s'est pas toujours le cas sur un départ
de paris-nice est ce que c'est un petit
plus quand même pour pour vos
administrés c'est un énorme plus parce
que s'il était tombé des cordes vous
imaginez un petit peu alors que là on a
beaucoup de chance ces femmes eu lieu en
algérie c'est la course du soleil donc
le soleil est au rendez vous au fort j
et qu'est ce que ça apporte à une petite
commune de recevoir le paris nice un
moment de fête comme je le disais c'est
vraiment un moment exceptionnel parce
que toute la population a joué le jeu et
puis j'ai la chance d'avoir une grosse
équipe de bénévoles qui nous ont
beaucoup aidés parce que ça nécessite
quand même de l'installation du mariage
et autres et donc
c'est vraiment c'est vraiment un bon
moment de fête voilà on met combien de
temps pour organiser un parent et nice
dans sa commune
entend pourrais pas vous dire quoi en
temps cumulés mais ça fait un mois qu'on
en parle et tous les jours on fait un
peu attention et puis plus on avance et
plus il faut y penser ne rien oublier
voilà c'est une belle visibilité aussi
pour la commune ouais c'est sympa c'est
super
qu'on parle un petit peu le flou je suis
ravi est ce que vous avez senti
l'effervescence monte au fur et à mesure
des aides et semaine depuis l annonce on
le voit derrière il ya beaucoup
d'enfants ils ont l'air ravis alors dans
le village pour le ménage n'ont pas eu
la joie non les enfants qu'ils sont
ravis je suis content pour eux parce
qu'on voit qu'il ya une belle animation
pour eux et j'espère que ça va être
aussi pour eux un grand moment de fête
aujourd'hui nous sommes dans la vallée
de chevreuse donc c'est formidable ça va
faire des belles images une belle
compétition c'est parti sur les chapeaux
de roue hier donc tous les ingrédients
sont réunis pour pour qu'on ait un grand
paris nice savez quand on part sur de
bonnes bases généralement on finit sur
de bonnes bases également donc ça donne
le ton pour pour la semaine qu'est ce
qui vous plaît dans cette petite commune
de faris ce qui me plaisent déjà je la
connais parce que je la prends assez
souvent à vélo et puis encore une fois
le
cyclisme doit aller partout on doit
aller dans les petites communes on amène
des champions notre stade c'est sur les
communes des petites communes donc les
champions viennent danser stade là donc
c'est merveilleux et puis bon on est
toujours bien accueilli bien évidemment
est ce que c'est le côté populaire du du
vélo du cyclisme qui rejaillit quand on
vient ici pour un départ et a boycotté
populaire oui forcément parce que quand
il joue comme je le disais tout à
l'heure le manque aux sports se
déplacent partout et donc on doit on
doit on doit apporter les champions dans
l'indre dans cette petite commune d'à
les spectateurs sont là les spectateurs
qui ne voit jamais ses champions donc on
les retrouve ici aujourd'hui et vous
savez dans la vallée de chevreuse une
culture cycliste beaucoup de gens
repense à cette vallée à vélo et je
crois que c'est la seule course
aujourd'hui professionnel qui parle dans
la région parisienne de paris fameux
paris ou dans la région parisienne donc
on redonne un petit peu toutes ces
valeurs qui ont été créés dans la vallée
de chevreuse avec anti dans auparavant
avec avec toute cette histoire du
cyclisme 7 vallées donc aujourd'hui
c'est un point important pour nous
[Musique]
le départ d'une course c'est aussi
l'occasion de découvrir à les vélos les
bus des équipes et surtout d'approcher
les coureurs position très beaux ils
sont en carbone j'aimerais bien en avoir
un mais bon mes moyens me le permettent
pas ça c'est sûr
déjà la technicité quoi les dérailleurs
électriques sans fil les choses comme ça
qu'on annonce c'est l'impressionnant
quoi c'est vrai que c'est un peu petit
trouve c'est bizarre ça fait bizarre
c'est un petit peu petit mais vraiment
ils sont magnifiques là ça donne envie
de rouler avec comme des très beaux
vélos et on voit qu'ils ont tous sont
tous des cas c est ils sont tous ont
toutes un dérailleur électrique on voit
que ils sont à la pointe de la
technologie au niveau vélo
après c'est moi il ya des choses que
j'aime pas voyez c'est les freins les
freins à disque je suis pas tu plutôt
bien des générations par rapport à ça ce
lundi 7 mars il ya plusieurs centaines
de curieux présents dans ce village
évinois je suis aux côtés de jackie un
supporter un fan de cyclisme et vous
êtes du coi aussi bine j'habite en
eure-et-loir mais justine et à saint
arnoult dans les yvelines et voila quoi
j'ai pratiqué un peu le cycliste en
étant jeune donc bah ça se perd pas on
vient voir un peu
c'est dans les gènes quoi et vous venez
tout le temps tout le temps je viens
tout le temps voir paris nice je fais
des étapes du tour de france et bah vous
m'aidez on est on est dedans donc on
vient est ce que ça vous choque ou ça
vous surprend ce côté populaire on voit
qu'il ya énormément de monde aujourd'hui
non ça me choque pas et puis et puis
c'est pas comme moi c'est gratuit 1
la route c'est comme le foot voilà c'est
ça le truc est ce qui est aussi
intéressant ces convois d'aidé il ya des
maisons juste derrière une maison d'un
de vos amis est d'ailleurs assez un ami
qui habite juste derrière laquelle qu'on
va travailler ensemble pendant plus de
30 ans dans la même usine yorkais la
proximité il ya les maisons il ya les
cyclistes qui sont juste à côté le
maillot jaune va être à à deux pas de sa
maison bien sûr et puis ça gêne personne
5 et bien ses spectateurs ont pu voir le
premier maillot jaune de ce paris-nice
2022 christophe laporte tout heureux
d'être à l'honneur ce jour là auffargis
j'ai pas l'envié de maïon et wenn
maintenant je vais aller
j
-c jura quand je vois les photos sont
encore en cours hier soir mais oui c'est
sûr c'était vraiment une belle journée
pour moi et pour l'équipe
le départ était donné à 12h15 précise
direction orléans les cyclistes du
paris-nice reviendront l'année prochaine
pour une nouvelle édition dans les
yvelines
on continue par du football on l'a tous
suivi mardi dernier l'épopée du fc
versailles 78 s'est terminée en demi
finale de la coupe de france les versets
ils se sont inclinés 2 à 0 sur la
pelouse de nice dans un match palpitant
pour nous parler de sa défaite avec les
honneurs nous recevons deux joueurs du
club m'a quant à traoré et kevin femmes
bas bonsoir messieurs
avant de parler de ce match de coupe de
france on va tout d'abord revenir sur ce
match versailles nice qui s'est déroulé
ce mardi 1er mars à l'alliance riviera
nicolas lhenry nous vous nous avez
rejoint sur ce plateau bon soir alors
expliquez nous qu'est ce qui s'est passé
pendant ce match c'est un match qui
s'est déroulé en deux temps michael en
première période et trois divisions
d'écart ne se font pas vraiment
ressentir les versailles et contiennent
bien les assauts des joueurs de la côte
d'azur malgré quelques frayeurs le
gardien dan delaunay garde ses cages
inviolées versailles se procure même une
demi occasion avec ce ballon chipé par
inzaghi diarrassouba au niveau du milieu
de terrain mais le joueur est rattrapé
par les défenseurs niçois et diego
michel n'arrive pas à cadrer le score à
la pause 0 0 et puis en seconde période
versailles crack versailles crack
rapidement même trop rapidement le
joueur en forme du moment a mis une
grille profite d'une petite faute de
marquage sur ce centre pour ouvrir le
score sur cette belle frappe dans la
lucarne killen qui ne laisse aucune
chance au gardien versailles et on joue
la 48e minute versailles tente de réagir
mais sur cet exploit personnel d'amis
nouyrit encore lui nice va doubler la
mise avec ce but de dole berg à la 73e
minute comme on le dit dans le jargon la
messe est dite pourtant les versailles
et ne se démobilise pas il y aura
quelques situations comme sur ce centre
avec cette tête de christopher iba oui
mais la tête de l'attaquant n'est pas
assez forte les niçois auront l'occasion
de mettre le troisième but mais la barre
sauve le gardien de la cité royale 2 à 0
ce sera le score final versailles n'a
pas absolue n'a absolument pas à rougir
de sa performance dans cette rencontre
je n'ai qu'une seule chose à dire on se
donne rendez vous les prochaines merci
nicolas dans dreamhack en traoré une
semaine après cette rencontre comment
analysez vous cette ce match
après on est on est fier du parcours
qu'on a on a parcouru et on se dit que
ben voilà on va se servir de ce match
face à nice pour bien finir cette saison
et atteindre les objectifs qui vous
était donné kevin 2 à 0 est ce que c'est
dur ou pas finalement
c'est dur commun après ils ont eu
beaucoup d'occasions on a essayé de
revenir au score mais on sait deux ans
c'est trop découvert donc on a pris le
deuxième but mais on peut être fier du
parcours qu'on a fait est ce qu'à un
moment vous êtes dit c'est possible
kevin
bas on prend le but assez trop
rapidement en seconde période donc après
on essaie de revenir au score donc pour
l'espèce des espaces et ils ont joué un
compte ils ont eu des bons contres et
compliqué pour revenir au score
makan traoré à la mi temps vous êtes pas
dit finalement il ya de la place on peut
peut-être aller aux tirs au but est
passé
ben je pense que dans les têtes de
chacun sait ce qu'il a à prédominer
après ce n'est pas dit ouvertement mais
c'est clair que quand quand on arrive à
0 0 face à cette équipe de nice on s'est
dit que oui tout est possible d
espérer répéter le même scénario que
celui face à toulouse alors vous avez
senti la différence de niveau entre la
nationale 2 et la ligue 1 sur cette
rencontre
est ce qu'on ressent vraiment un m'as
camp oui forcément il ya beaucoup plus
d'intensité les joueurs sont beaucoup
plus de fait si techniquement c'est ils
sont tous uchida moyenne donc oui on a
vu du niveau d'écart entre les deux
championnats et de division par kevin
vous avez le même sentiment
elles sont plus costauds ça va plus vite
ouais on a senti la différence
différence quand même
que c'est le réalisme qui est le plus
important dans le football en ligue 1
peut être qu'on est plus tueur que quand
nationale 2 devant le but
c'est sabaya
comment dire oui en ligue 1 par exemple
on ne peut pas se permettre de faire
certaines fautes en nationale 2 on peut
se permettre de faire certaines petites
erreurs et et l'adversaire n'en profite
pas et là on a vu face à nice notamment
moi je sors un peu en retard sur le
joueur et en profiter pour faire cette
galaxie entreprises et mettre le premier
but il ya de la déception quand on perd
contre nice où finalement on se dit on
perd contre aunis une ligue 1 c'est le
football ils étaient plus forts que nous
mc ans et ensuite kevin iwuy ya
forcément de la déception parce qu'on
est tous des compétiteurs on aurait aimé
gagner aller au stade de france
lorsqu'on sait pas si on réussira un
jour à réitérer cette performance dans
notre carrière donc forcément un air de
dessiner après voilà avec un peu de
recul on réalise quand même le parcours
trône a fait on a quand même fil du
match et on est quand même contents et
fiers d'avoir perdu face à cette belle
équipe de nice qui a quand même faut pas
l'oublier sorti le psg et marseille les
tours précédents
kevin
je pense exactement comme à caen on est
déçu puisqu'on aurait bien aimé aller au
stade de france et aussi joué pour une
fois en ile de france parce qu'on a fait
et qu'elle à l'extérieur mais après on
est on est très fiers du parcours qu'on
a fait et il faut pas oublier que kanye
c'est son troisième de ligue 1 et c'est
un gros morceau comme
ce macho a touché le coeur à des
supporters à verser is été très nombreux
à vous suivre dans les bars de la ville
on regarde ce reportage de justin brasil
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
versailles face à nice un club de
nationale 2 face à un club de ligue 1 le
coup d'envoi a été donné à 21h ce mardi
1er mars les supporters yvelinois ont
suivi cette demi finale de coupe de
france de football de près la première
mi temps elles sont accrochés jusqu'au
bout il ya eu 0 0 deuxième mi temps je
pense que la fatigue s'est accumulée
malheureusement bat la différence de
niveau s'est fait ressentir et on s'est
pris de but mais bon on saura quel
honneur dans ce peuple situé rue colbert
à versailles ils étaient près de 150 à
être venus soutenir l'équipe locale soit
y aller quand même pas mal de monde une
belle ambiance c'est sûr que j'ai passés
par mardi ordinaire comme d'habitude
donc
c'est toujours un gros plus les bars et
les pubs versailles est une alternative
pour ceux qui n'ont pas pu faire le
déplacement à nice ceux qui n'ont pas pu
suivre la rencontre 2 chez eux ou encore
pour ceux qui voulaient tout simplement
profiter de l'ambiance versaillaise
[Applaudissements]
on est derrière notre club donc c'est là
derrière notre ville c'est assez rare
donc c'était assez puissant sané super
plaisir il y avait une super ambiance en
bas bon on n'a pas gagné mais on a vibré
ce soir match sympa on a tous un bon
moment en tout cas je suis contente
quand même
vincent était cool que vers 5 gagnent le
fc versailles et le cinquième club de
nationale 2 accéder aux demi finales de
coupe de france de football un parcours
historique pour le club même s'il aurait
aimé voir un but tous s'accordent à
saluer cette performance inédite conçue
de leurs portants ils ont fait plaisir
ce soir ils sortent franchement ils ont
fait un bon match sur un ballon en
vouloir et à leur merci pour nous avoir
fait vivre
on perd 2-0 mais ils ont vraiment pas à
rougir je suis un peu triste mais
vraiment je suis plus fier parce que ils
ont fait le taff août ont pas démérité
france qui doit être fière de ses fils
de voir que larissa y arriva
si le club versailles et s'est incliné 2
0 face à nice certains supporters y
croient déjà pour l'année prochaine
c'est encourageant en plus le club monte
en puissance donc on y croit on se dit
que m
chaque année c'est pas la première fois
il ya deux trois ans on est aussi monté
on a aussi bien jouer en coupe de france
j'espère que
voiles et voiliers prochaine on y croit
en attendant les supporters du fc
versailles espère voir le club de
national de monter d'une division en
national
kevin qu'est ce que ça vous fait de voir
à ces images de bar bondé à à versailles
bah c'est cool c'est
son nom a suscité de l'intérêt on a les
gens étaient contents donc c'est
vraiment c'est vraiment bien c'est cool
quand est-ce que vous avez le sentiment
d'avoir mis peut-être versailles sur la
carte du football français avec cette
épopée
moi je pense que oui ça me le fait
maintenant lumière après faux billets
qui entourait qui avait été fait les
années précédentes
avec les montées successives de terrain
n3 n2 mais oui je pense ce parcours on a
mis le club a encore un peu plus en
lumière est-ce que ce parcours va vous
servir pour la suite en championnat vous
êtes actuellement premier vous avez
gagné le week-end dernier 3-0 face à
château voltigeurs de châteaubriant
est ce que ça vous a permis de remporter
cette victoire et d'espérer encore plus
d'être deux
d'aller en nationale une année prochaine
kevin oui je pense que ce parcours va
nous servir il a animé cette fin de
saison et c'est très bien pour le groupe
kevin
band façon l'objectif numéro un du club
c'est la montée en national donc c'est
bien qu'on puisse repartir à direct
après après cette coupe de france sur
une victoire et en espérant qu'on pour
continuer repartir une série de
victoires pour la montée en national il
reste dix matches joués qu'est ce qu'il
faudra faire pour monter à votre avis
kevin est ensuite ma quand kevin en
premier
continuez plancher de
tous solidaires c'est tout un groupe
c'est tout un groupe et il faut rester
motivés concentrés et sa voiture est
maintenant
comme il a dit kevin il faudra continuer
sur ce qu'on a fait depuis deux saisons
c'est à dire travailler
toujours être solidaire a rechigné et
puis il ya aussi des joueurs qui nous
ont rejoints à l'intersaison qui vont
pouvoir nous aider à bien finir ce
championnat pour ce qu'à la fin ça va
être difficile rowling donc vraiment
tout le groupe il faut que tout le
groupe reste concerné que tous les
groupes sociaux des
merci à tous les deux merci d'être
intervenu dans cette émission bon
courage pour la suite de la saison
continuera évidemment à vous suivre sur
tv soixante dix huit merci beaucoup
alors à présent sur les résultats
sportifs du week-end dans les yvelines
avec vous nicolas landry on commence par
du rugby oui mickaël en fédérale 2 pour
le compte de la 18e journée du
championnat le club de plaisir recevez
la baule et les plaisirs wallon emporté
dans la douleur 26 à 19 sur leur terrain
une victoire importante pour la suite du
championnat les yvelinoises sont
septièmes à 4 points de la sixième place
l'aps la place qui est qualificative
pour les phases finales on joue
également en fédérale 3 et dans la poule
une nosy be nord et d'asie ont réalisé
un carton plein versailles s'est imposé
41 à 14 face à rouen universités maisons
laffitte écrase diète 62 à 26 et enfin
où il domine largement en petite
couronne 61 à 7 après 14 journées
versailles est toujours leader devant la
mls gp et houilles du basket à présent
et dans le championnat de nationale 3
trappe continue sa marche en avant les
trappistes se sont imposés 95 à 86 à
domicile face au cercle sportif bayeux
lors de la 18e journée dans la même
poule marly le roi est allé chercher la
victoire sur le terrain de caen le score
86 à 77 au classement le fc trappes est
en deuxième position avec 32 points
marly le roi est toujours le bon dernier
de la poule merci pour toutes ces
précisions nicolas lundi prochain on
retrouvera un autre spécialiste des
résultats sportifs du week-end dans le
département bixente mériaux senti steban
je vous propose de terminer par une
aventure elles s'élanceront en novembre
prochain pour le raid des alizés en
martinique un raid solitaire 100%
féminin zoé sophie et stéphanie sont en
pleine préparation physique et mentale
pour l'épreuve nous les avons rencontrés
sur l'un de leurs lieux d'entraînement à
saint germain en laye ni tableau exprès
par bixente mérian santisteva
[Applaudissements]
le reste des alizés je les fais en 2019
c'est génial c'est fatigant éprouvant on
fait de la compétition des épreuves
toute la journée on se lève à 4h du mat
jusqu'à 16h façon après 16 heures il
fait nuit il se passe en martinique et
on se fait le trail de la montagne pelée
sylla il est beau mais il est très très
très éprouvant les distances des
épreuves sont dévoilés que la veille du
coup on sait le soir avant de se coucher
que le lendemain au réveil on partira
pour 20 km de trail à la montagne pelée
ou plus
c'est un raid qui nous tient à coeur
parce que déjà c'est une vraie épreuve
sportive
avec pendant 4 5 jours 4 5 jours
vraiment des épreuves de canoë de vtt de
trail de concertation et d épreuve
surprise c'est un raid qui nous tient à
coeur parce qu'on défend du coup
l'association disait forever
c'est une association qui vise à lutter
contre le cancer pédiatrique la petite
lisa est décédé à l'aube de ses quatre
ans d'une tumeur cérébrale et c'est une
association qui est pas qu est pas très
loin de chez nous et qui fait beaucoup
de bruit qui est très sportive et
organise beaucoup d'événements
je me suis mis aux trails et la course à
pied il ya environ cinq ans et je suis
devenu une addict complète je me suis
mise à la course à pied en 2013 de
mémoire et la l1 j'ai enchaîné les
courses notamment avec sophie ont fait
pas mal de courses ensemble ouais je
cours depuis que suis toute petite j'ai
dû faire ma première compétition à
quatre ans et demi cinq ans depuis
depuis je cours
on va se préparer physiquement à la
s'entraîner ça on a pas mal de courses
aussi prévus du coup la chacune ensemble
ou séparément du coup d'ondés gros
traits et la marathon voilà les choses
comme ça
[Applaudissements]
c'est la fin cette émission merci
d'avoir suivi à bientôt sur tv 78
[Musique]